turn to my right and he is the si.com
college football analyst and he'll will
be on the sidelines of army taking on at
the Ohio State University at the
Horseshoe on Fox and joining us here for
the Direct TV 4k college football report
in person is Bruce Feldman good to see
you sir good to be here before we get to
Ohio State where you will be I want to
talk about the team that beat them in
the war shoot last week in Oklahoma and
Baker Mayfield who planted the flag
carve them up knotted the OL with a game
the score wasn't even a reflection of
how much I thought Oklahoma dominated
that game so look I mean he's the top of
my Heisman list right now because nobody
has had a more impressive showing than
he did we actually had oh you week one
and they look really sharp he only
played a half the offensive lines really
good but I think what people really need
to acknowledge with him is they lost
Dede Westbrook who won the Bullitt Nick
off award they lost Joe Mixon and semaj
P Ryan who were two of the best running
backs they've ever had there so it
wasn't like he had a lot of skill guys
and he went up against an Ohio State
defense where a lot of people think it's
the best deepest defensive line and he
just cut them apart I mean it's quite a
show by him well what does Lincoln is
Lincoln Riley brought something
different then Stoops I think it's just
a team that has grown and gotten closer
together I mean I talked to those guys
earlier this week about that a lot of
credit to linked Arantes his first
career road game as a head coach and he
had a great game plan today attacked a
lot of weak spots they found with OSU
but also I thought some of the things he
set up I mean that guy's running free
and good credit to Baker to act the way
he executed but I think you know Lincoln
Riley you give him an a-plus-plus for
how he responded you don't usually see
Urban Meyer and his staff get out coach
like that and then you know the planting
of the flag in the middle of the field
for which Baker Mayfield apologized on
Monday and we had him on Tuesday show
and you know we joke with them like when
you make a chess move you keep your
finger on the piece and it's not
officially a chess move until your
fingers removed it seemed like his
finger was still on the flag yesterday I
went back in time I wouldn't necessarily
go back and you know do it any
differently it was what it was it
happened it was an emotional and I think
we deserved it we deserve to celebrate
and every bit of it but
a lot of sensitive people in this world
in this day and age so you know I'm
gonna offend a lot of people you know
the nature of being additional man
that's what you had to say
that's Baker being Baker you know look
it wasn't like he flipped off the
stadium so I think we should keep this
in some context I think in Baker's mind
he looked at and go while they were
singing on our their fight song on our
field last year and this was him one up
in them he doesn't have to go play them
in Columbus again if he ever gets to see
him again maybe it'll be in the playoff
and that's a stretch so you know look I
don't think in the grand scheme of
things we've seen a lot more offensive
stuff and I do think people get outraged
and different things but I was sitting
there on Saturday when I saw him like
he's gonna do this isn't he and sure
enough he jammed it right into the heart
of it well Fowler you I know you're
buddies with going back in the day he
saw it coming - he's like he's not gonna
plant that flag is he is he gonna really
do that and him right down there in the
field turf yeah it's Baker being Baker
you know so what about Ohio Stan Bruce
Feldman here on the Rich Eisen show what
about Bruce though Ohio State's
quarterback situation with JT Barrett I
mean he's as successful a quarterback as
we've seen in recent memory
but when Ohio State falls behind it
doesn't appear to be a dynamic enough
offense with him at the controls is that
a fair assessment it's I mean look it is
what it is right now they did not
respond well to that I think that you're
seeing a lot of zones that they struggle
with and it's not just JT Barrett I
think one of the issues is Urban Meyer
has recruited really well you look at
all these four and five star guys
there's a lot of speed for some reason
they have not been able to develop you
know receivers to take it even further
there's just not a proven go-to guy I
don't know if they have a great feel for
for what's going on out there finding
finding open space JT's accuracy you
know which we heard in the offseason I
remember being in Columbus in spring you
know urban was very encouraged Kevin
Wilson came in he's a really well
regarded offensive coach Ryan Day is a
very well thought of quarterback coach
so they given him the pieces to take it
to the next step but it hasn't
translated now Urban Meyer in the wake
of all this has been very adamant you
know there is no we're not looking for
anybody else it's JT JT is the only
three-time cap
the storied history of Ohio State so
we're not just talking about just a
regular guy this is an interesting
dynamic I think what you hear from some
Ohio State fans is hey you got Dwayne
Hoskins you know we had urban on our
podcast on signing day last year and
urban told us
Dwayne askings is the best pure passer
he'd ever seen at that stage and so it
was like people like wait a minute this
guy because that would seem to be the
guy who does all the stuff JT struggling
with but I think if you're an Ohio State
fan you have to respect you know Urban
Meyer's out all the practices he's in
all you know there was all the meetings
they know who's ready and who's not if
it was as simple as join Haskins is
gonna make their offense much better
I think Dwayne Haskins would be the guy
you know they you have to trust your
staff to know what they know but I think
right now Urban is dealing with making
sure this thing doesn't really mushroom
and give it more oxygen by saying okay
well we're gonna consider it well I mean
plus the schedule is soft enough that
that maybe everything can calm down
there or you take a look at what
happened with Sam Donald last year with
the USC to think that maybe just maybe
this is a situation similar that they
need to just say okay JD I know you're
the first three-time captain here and
you've got heart and you've got soul and
you represent the school so well but we
do have to win football games and we got
to get this kid in the soft part of the
schedule right now let's get him up to
speed
I think the difference there is max
Brown was the guy at USC he really
hadn't you know proven anything in games
where as JT Barrett you know he finished
fifth in the Heisman I think is you know
three years ago he has done a lot of
good things he does fit in some level of
what they want to do in the quarterback
run game probably even more so than
Haskins does the the issues I think are
bigger than just JT Barrett in terms of
the vertical passing him I really think
a lot of it is on the receivers you also
watch that game and and and Dobbins
they're terrific freshman running back
he looks awesome but it's like are you
gonna feed him more you know it's like I
think there's some there's a questions
about the play calling a little bit and
look it's only their second game as a
staff together you know I think it'll
get better as you say I mean army comes
in there this is the they're on a
five-game winning streak for the
program's first time in like 21 years
are they really gonna challenge this
you know this team because Iowa State's
biggest issue their last and pass
defense
well Army comes in they've completed two
passes all your combined so I think this
is probably an interesting set up for
them to try to get some momentum and
gets things sorted out and maybe we'll
see Duane Haskins in some of these games
as these you know it's really turn out
to be blowouts si.com college football
analysts and also Fox sideline reporter
Bruce Feldman here in the DirecTV for K
college football report how do you see
Clemson and Louisville shakin out this
weekend
you know Clemson was awesome last
weekend 11 sacks against Auburn and Gus
Malzahn offense I think what what we've
seen so far Lamar Jackson has been
fantastic I mean you can say what you
want about Bobby Petrino is like a human
being
here are your highs but he knows what
he's doing as a as a coach and an
offensive coach and it looks like Lamar
Jackson has really elevated his game
we're gonna find out way more cuz this
is the best defensive front in college
football right now I mean Dexter
Lawrence is first pick of the draft kind
of talent and guy Carlos Watkins these
guys are studs but the Louisville
offensive line was the Achilles heel
last year it was really exposed by
Houston who had a good defensive front
and it was really exposed by LSU in the
bowl game I think and I think Ella
Louisville has a legit chance to win
this game I think they will because
right now I think what people for kind
of overlooking is the impact of not
having to Shawn Watson running that
offense I mean they lost a lot of good
players on offense but I think to
Shawn's big game presence is something
they'll miss Louisville almost beat them
last year on the road and I think they
will get them and I think what we may be
looking at is that guy you know we've
never seen anybody win a Heisman in
consecutive years in 40-plus years
Lamar comes out of there and lead them
to a victory against what clemson is I
think people will have to take it really
seriously that he has a child
Bruce Feldman in the DirecTV 4k college
football report before I let you go what
did you think of James Franklin's
postgame comments where he back slapped
Pitt and Penn State fans say he was just
equated this game to any other game by
throwing Akron its name out there and
other folks think that he was being
disrespectful what where do you stand on
this
you know what I don't have any problem
with some of this stuff you know I like
both him and Patton are doozie they're
both feisty guys and I think it's good
for the rivalry I think we need more
rivalries like this I mean to me the
disrespectful is flipping somebody off
for doing something like you know him
him kind of throwing them under you know
like under the bus a little bit it's not
just Pitt it's bringing Akron's name
into it after you just waxed Akron the
week before yeah I don't know I think
that we were pulling hamstrings to try
to try to justify you know somebody
being slighted or anything like that so
you didn't think much of it I didn't
think much of it I I think there's
enough stuff for us to get outraged on
other place what else what else you got
that's a long story it's too much to go
into right now the DirecTV 4k college
football game of the week this week is
Northern Illinois against Nebraska
that's this very Saturday tune in to
channel 106 this Saturday at 1:00
Eastern Time and 10:00 a.m. Pacific it
is the Direct TV 4k college football
game of the week only available on
DirecTV and you were in Nebraska
I saw Nebraska last week in or again in
Oregon is out there okay so what
happened what would you think they're
two really good quarterbacks I think
both guys you'll see in the NFL Jerry
Jarrett Leigh is that um I'm sorry
blanking on Nebraska the two lane
transfer he really has talent but I
think it's just a they got to get a
little more rhythm I think with the
young receivers defensively Nebraska is
really bad they played better in the
second half it's Bobby deuce it's only
his second game they're running the
defense then when you see with Oregon
Justin Herbert you know you hear about
all these great quarterbacks in the
pac-12 Donald rose and Jake browning
Luke flop I think Justin Herbert
eventually will be a first-round pick
Zach Taylor Tony's name what's up the
kid's name Zach the quarterback I'm
blanking so much on it's okay man you
just it's it's such an early part of the
marathon to called the college
football's bad because I just did this
game okay it's okay
like LSU quarterback you're focused on
Ohio State taking on army yeah I feel
like we like James Franklin now it's
just oh hi Oh State Army oh that's it
Northern Illinois against Nebraska is
again the DirecTV Fork a college
football game are we good to see a Bruce
come back to the pleasure I love it
that's Bruce Feldman of si.com and
college football analyst on Fox as well
when we come back it'll be Mike Lombardi
of the ringer sitting here right in this
seat and speaking of that he's put the
ring in the ringer Brockman the Patriots
Super Bowl ring is here is here in the
house it's a thing of beauty man it is
as big as Foxboro Stadium I don't know
how he's gonna be able to fit into the
chair wow it looks like something out of
Game of Thrones a finger it does in fact
you could also perform surgery I think
it you can have an agency perform knee
surgery with that thing it's good to see
you Bruce development Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to